I used to jump straight into the vacancy
I'd be like hi this is Amber from Irving
Knight seen that you're hiring on
LinkedIn what are you looking for
they're not going to remember me they're
not going to remember that I'm called
Amber they're not going to know anything
about me other than a voice that they've
heard on the phone they don't understand
anything about my knowledge or my
business so you know leaving the vacancy
part of the call till the very end that
should occupy such a minimal amount of
that call and the calls should not be
lasting for 10 minutes and you come off
and start headhunting for them how the
heck are you going to know enough about
someone's business and their pain and
how to solve that in 10 minutes you're
just not I typically like to aim for at
least an hour to two hours